جيك، علينا أن نلقي نظرة على الأمريكان الذين يأخذون نفسًا
عميقًا، ما يحدث في
غزة الآن هو
كارثة إنسانية مروعة، فنحن ننظر
إلى
23000 شخص قتلوا، وحوالي
60000 أصيبوا بجروح
وثلثي الأشخاص الذين تعرضوا للقتل.
القتلى هم من النساء والأطفال، أنت
تنظر إلى 70% من الوحدات السكنية في
غزة التي تم تدميرها. جاك إذا
استخدمت كلمة رئيس ألمانيا،
فإنك تفكر في الدمار المروع
خلال الحرب العالمية الثانية لتلك المدينة وما
يجري فيها.  غزة الآن خلال ثلاثة أشهر
أسوأ مما حدث في دريسدن
على مدى عامين. هذه
كارثة والآن وفقا
للأمم المتحدة بعد أن يكون لديك 1.9
مليون شخص نزحوا من
منازلهم، ليس لديهم طعام لا يملكونه.  ليس لديهم
ماء، ليس لديهم
معدات طبية، ليس لديهم وقود، ما
تنظرون إليه هو مجاعة وشيكة،
الأطفال يتضورون جوعا حتى الموت، وعلى
الكونجرس الأمريكي أن يتحرك
لأن الكثير من هذا الدمار
يحدث بالأسلحة العسكرية
المقدمة  من قبل الولايات المتحدة
الأمريكية